in Dearborn Michigan there is an amazing
museum with a sealed test tube
containing the final breath of a great
American hero or villain depending on
who you ask Henry Ford idolized Thomas
Edison he was his boyhood hero and so
when they finally met when Ford was in
his 30s it must have been a great relief
to find that Edison was a kindred spirit
someone who understood his dreams and
ambitions they remained friends until
Edison's dying days when he left Henry
Ford a very intimate and peculiar gift
he gave Ford his dying breath Henry Ford
grew up on a rural farm without
electricity but he saw the meteoric rise
of Thomas Edison through the newspapers
this was his hero this was who Henry
Ford wanted to be at a General Electric
mixer he had a chance to talk to Edison
and tell him about this project he'd
been working on on the side
the Ford quadricycle Edison was
impressed he slammed his hand on the
table and said young man that's the
thing you have it the two of them became
fast friends and will remain so for the
rest of their lives they even bought
houses next to each other in Florida
they would go on camping trips together
and these camping trips would include
naturalist John Burroughs President
Warren Harding Firestone of Firestone
tires Burbank of the Burbank potato
these were like a who's who of
industrialist magnates
and they'd let go would make a campfire
and like you know roast weenies and the
two of them just got closer as time went
on when Edison was confined to a
wheelchair
Ford bought his own so they could have a
wheelchair races which is just
incredibly cute Edison equally loved
Ford he said as to Henry Ford words are
inadequate to express my feelings I can
only say that in the fullest meaning of
the word he is my friend
the funny thing is is both of these guys
were notorious
monsters kind of I mean Edison
infamously electrified an elephant
screwed Tesla out of money generally
treated his workers like dirt ford
fought in unionization for as long and
as hard as he could he became an
anti-semite in later life these were
guys who didn't give a lot of concern to
the role of the little guy they saw in
each other
a very unique kind of striving so as a
legend goes for to ask Edison son
Charles to hold the test tube up to
Edison's mouth as he breathed his dying
breath and then quickly sealed it
the truth is slightly more prosaic there
were just a bunch of test tubes in the
room they filled with the air some of it
which was Edison's Bradford's of it
which was just air one of them was given
to Ford as a memento this was a very
personal object and actually Ford kept
it out of the public's awareness and in
his own private collection until after
he died it doesn't really matter whether
Edison's last breath is in that test
tube or not what is in there
his friendship a kind of friendship that
only two titans of industry could ever
forge subscribe here and watch more
videos here well I have a little coming
out then but that's because I'm getting
old but I got a lot of ginger yup